oh we originally planned this talk to
connect up with stoic week which is over
but we're at least in the same month as
it was a big growing movement of people
interested in stoic philosophy and in
applying it to modern life so just to
give you an idea at stoic on we had
about which was around the middle of the
month we had about 330 people show up it
was the largest gathering of Stoics in
history and there is something like
twenty or thirty thousand people on
stoicism reddit there's sixteen thousand
on the stoicism group in Facebook and
most of them are not students most of
them are people who are working because
they're they're finding stoicism useful
for them in one way or another so this
talk is is about stoicism has a moral
theory it's part of an ethics class so
figure nicely dumped he'll what you guys
are doing and I'd like you to think
about some of the other things you've
been studying in your ethics class some
of the examples and we'll see if we can
apply them to stoicism I've reserve some
time for questions and answer a
discussion at the end but I'm also you
know pretty happy to answer your
questions along the way anything that's
unclear I may take a pause here in there
and say if there see if there are any
questions so let's talk first about
really big picture stuff
where does stoic ethics fit in with
moral theories the sorts of things that
you're studying in an ethics class a lot
of people view stoicism has a particular
kind of virtue ethics and that makes
good sense because you see them talking
about these cardinal virtues like wisdom
and temperance or moderation courage
justice
I think you've encountered these in
other moral theories right so that makes
sense and then there's also a strong
emphasis on themes that come up with
what we call dant illogical ethics
because covered anthology
is the intro class mind you so you guys
how much of that moral theories
classical moral moral theories of you
guys so one of the big you know ones
that you encounter I know we have yeah
so so danto logical theories tend to
focus primarily on duty
I'm the notion of obligation on doing
what you ought to do what's right and
the Stoics really stressed that as well
there's also certain other key themes
like human freedoms you know figuring
out what sort of laws or rules you ought
to obey that that fit in with that as
well one thing that you can say that the
Stoics were definitely a poster or what
we call hedonistic ethics ethics that
say that pleasures is the good pain is
the bad
the Stoics were some of the strongest
opponents of that in in ancient times
and they remain so I think in the
present at the same time if we don't
look just at pleasure and pain than
other goods
sometimes the Stoics look like what we
call utilitarians where they try to you
know look at the outcomes across the
board and see what will work out well or
you could call it the system as a whole
or the community as a whole but they're
not thinking about that primarily in
terms of pain and pleasure they're
thinking about that in terms of other
things and the last thing to say about
this is you you may not encounter what's
called natural law theory in an intro
class or even in an ethics class it
depends on how it's being taught and
there's a lot of material that has to be
crammed into 15 weeks so we often have
to carry out kind of triage and cutting
things a lot but the Stoics are one of
the first people to start talking in
pretty robust terms about natural law
and by natural law what they mean is
that there'd be a kind of moral
structure written into or built into the
fabric of the universe and the structure
of the human person that you could
uncover through reason and then start
applying and you know there's a lot more
to it than that but that's sort of the
thumbnail sketch the other thing I want
to say sort of in preparation
we only think about what it is that we
want moral theories to do for us people
take an ethics class in general because
they have to write the required course
at some places some of the professions
that you'll go on to have codes of
ethics that you'll be expected to it's
not memorize at least don't get in
trouble with don't don't transgress
oftentimes ethics is looked at as
something that's you know imposed upon
us it's really good for us to study
ethics and you know all of you are going
to find that out as you move into your
professions now you could study moral
theories just because they're
intrinsically interesting that's not
something that I think appeals to most
people that doesn't feel to me and you
know that's how people become academics
but I think most people are interested
in in more practical matters right so
what are those some of them some of
those have to do with understanding how
to distinguish good and bad and right
from from wrong and why because those
are difficult things when you get into
real-life situations to make sense of if
it was easy if you could just sort of
consult you know your gut well then you
wouldn't need ethics at all
you'd be built into you but it doesn't
work that way is you find out when you
run into real situations again in
general it's not just about evaluating
actions is this action right or wrong
good or bad it also extends to thinking
about the kind of persons that we are
and our motivations and things like our
emotions and relationships all those
fall within the scope of ethics we
really want to understand moral theory
well when we get into difficult
situations and unfortunately if we
haven't spent much time not necessarily
studying ethics in an academic way but
at least thinking about these sorts of
things playing them in our head
reflecting on these sorts of things when
we get into difficult situations it's
it's pretty hard to learn on the fly if
we're really lucky we have somebody else
who's a great
counselor or advisor to give us some
useful you know principles or you know
proverbs or whatever you want to call it
or you're going to hold their hand and
walk us through something that's not
usually the case most of the time we're
on our own so it's important to have
some sort of ethical grounding it's not
enough you might say to have moral
compass you actually need to know how to
use that compass to to navigate through
the forest anybody it can have a moral
compass although I think so pupils are
probably in better shape than others so
we want epochs to help us out when we're
faced with temptations and I think you
know in your class you probably talked
about some of these these things that
come up some of them are very common to
students right like you know thinking
about should you go to a party or should
you study Saturday night that can be an
ethical question right especially if you
have an obligation to your team to do
well in your joint project or something
along those lines opposition by others
it's not just that you're gonna get
tempted to do things you're going to
encounter active opposition from other
people telling you that what you think
is good is actually bad and you
shouldn't do it or vice versa so that's
important to be able to have to handle
we do run into genuine moral dilemmas
from time to time usually because things
have gotten screwed up there's a whole
literature out there on moral dilemmas
that's very interesting some people say
they don't really exist I think they
really do why do they exist while we get
ourselves into messy situations and then
we have to figure out what we're doing
so ethics can give us a nice bigger
picture way of looking at things can
give us some ideals by which we can
orient ourselves it can tell us or at
least it should tell us what the good
for human beings is and how we can work
towards that or as I like to put it a
lot of times ethics is not just about
this you know can we measure up through
our idea our ideals it's also about well
we've managed to really screw things up
now how do we unscrew them overtime and
how do we know that we're not getting
ourselves deeper into into the mess
that's also part of ethics and the
Stoics we'll talk about that the other
thing that the that ethics ought to do
is help us identify both in general and
in our particular cases what obstacles
are standing in our way when it comes to
personal development when it comes to
doing the right thing when it comes to
thinking things through
so the Stoics had a lot to say about all
those different things there and they're
they're not the only people who do
there's plenty of other great schools
and approaches that you should you
should study but I think the Stoics have
some interesting things to offer so
before we go into some of the like the
meets any any questions about or
comments about this so far issues
ejections worries all right so let's
jump in I'm giving you a real thumbnail
sketch and when we say thumbnail sketch
you know think of like a video of
thumbnail you really can't see much of
anything on it can you can see maybe a
little you know tiny thing there you
blow off the phone now but it's usually
very pixelated that's the way this
sketch is going to be we're not gonna in
the 30 minutes that remain to us walk
through the entire new stoic ethics so
we're not four-man things and try to do
those fairly well and I'll answer any
questions that you have along the way
about these so let's talk about the good
in the bad this is really fundamental
the Stoics are you might say hardliners
and they were understood as hardliners
even in ancient times and they are even
so today including for the modern
adapters with stoicism who often seem to
like to want to shave off some of the
rough edges or make it a little bit
easier to adapt to modern life the
Stoics thought that what's fundamentally
good is at the core of the human person
it's not out there in the world
except in a derivative sense it's not in
money it's not in pleasure
it lies in what they called virtue and
that's an old-fashioned term you guys
have been hopefully introduced to it but
it's something that's hard for us
sometimes to wrap our head around think
about words that we use instead of
character or good traits personality
those are those are things that are
structured by by virtue so the stoic
said that that virtue and the things
that go along with it like emotions
thoughts actions those are what is good
and those are also what is bad so the
good and the bad lie primarily in the
human person and his or her actions his
or her motivations his or her thoughts
and feelings the stoic said some
feelings are good some feelings are bad
bad for us so strictly speaking it's
it's you know moral character they they
understood this in a variety of
different ways sometimes they would talk
about living in accordance with nature
that requires a little bit of
explanation later on one of the people
who you studied epictetus talks about
having one's Faculty of choice in
accordance with nature sometimes it's
translated as will although that's a
little it's going a bit too far but what
it is in us that that chooses should be
in accordance with with nature and not
just nature like nature red in tooth and
claw via videos for that expression
before you know like well everybody's
out to screw everybody else that's not
what the Stoics mean nature that's the
screwed-up world nature means properly
developed human nature what it is that
we have the potential to be what it is
that that people that we look up to
actually exhibit so everything else is
what they call indifferent this is I
think where the storage lose a lot of
people if you look at what they include
in the realm of indifference they say
things like life isn't indifferent it's
better to die virtuous than to live
vicious they would say that's that's a
hard one but I think for a lot of people
health health isn't indifference in
illness its opposite isn't indifferent
beauty in a physical attractiveness
strength pleasure pleasure and pain are
indifference wealth fame or as we would
call it today celebrity right whether
you're on TV or not how many what he
likes you get on your your Facebook
posts or well Facebook doesn't have
dislike down
that's an indifferent to the to the
stories the family that you're born into
the social class that you inhabit all
these things it's not to say that
they're bad they're just not morally
valuable now it gets a little bit more
complicated than that because then the
Stoics go and say well some of these are
what we call preferred sort of made-up
terminology when they didn't have the
right terms some of these are preferred
in a difference because they can lead to
virtue it's it's easier in some respects
if you're healthy to live a virtuous
life than if you're constantly sick and
being driven nuts by it you know for
example the Stoics thought that anger
was a bad thing in general we can talk a
little bit more about that later on if
you want to but just sort of start with
that principle anger is a bad thing when
you're when you're sick don't you lose
your temper more easily when you're
healthy it's hopefully you don't lose
your temper quite so quick that doesn't
make it Boldin to lose your temper okay
so there's a lot of things where these
indifference could in fact serve the
good or serve the bad but by themselves
they're not really valuable that's what
the Stoics think that people who say
that earning wealth is the from the end
of everything and you measure a person's
worth by their wealth
the Stoics saying those people are
actually mixed up they're in a bad state
they they are in a vice of the opposite
of wisdom foolishness and we can say
that for a lot of other things as well
so you know this is this is a point
where I think a lot of people say well
that sounds very harsh and we'll see how
harsh it is as we get to it so that's
another good place I think applause how
many of you think that at this point you
can sort of get behind the it's a
fundamentally matters it's character
whether you're virtuous or vicious and
everything else is will make it a little
bit easier for you
everything everything else isn't
strictly speaking and different but it
doesn't matter it as much as your
character how many of you can buy into
that and not that many some okay how
many do could actually go the whole
stoic route and say just virtue advice
that's the only thing that matters
wealth doesn't matter to me at all
health is indifference I can be just as
happy Hill as I am healthy no takers all
up on that yeah like when the Stoics say
health is and indifferent yeah that's
correct
it's just struggle with that idea I mean
it's makes sense from the standpoint of
what's up to us or not up to us that
make sure that they may but help is
something we can willfully kind of
influence quite quite significantly
right so I was yes what did they how do
we work that out I mean it seems like
you it is up to us to some degree and
therefore it's not an indifferent in
that sense you know yeah I mean that we
can control so it gets a little bit more
complicated and then the next thing
we'll talk about is what's in our
control and what's not in our control at
thee there's two things to be said about
health one is that the Stoics say you do
actually have a responsibility to
maintain your body and health because
it's it's part of what you got you know
the things that are in different their
external including your body but our use
of them is not indifferent so it's sort
of like you know think about your body
is like a lawn mower when you put your
lawn mower away to clean the stuff out
from the bottom
you know and so the jams move you need
it not to
that's that's your fault right no if the
manufacturer you know left out of bolt
or something and it shakes itself apart
well that's not your problem at all
right body there's lots of things that
eventually go wrong
those are very unfortunately you're not
experiencing too much of this at this
point but you will sooner or later all
sorts of crazy things that you wouldn't
have any idea could go wrong with your
body starting start going off here and
there and that's not really you can you
can make sure that you know you're
eating a proper diet alright you're
exercising like it's a if you don't want
to get diabetes right
what don't you what shouldn't you do if
you don't want to get diabetes say drink
to a half liter two to two litre gallons
of soda to two liter bottles of a soda a
day you don't want to get diabetes
that's probably a good place to start
right there's other things you can do as
well but you can do all those things and
you can still get diabetes and I mean if
it's your choice how do you manage your
diabetes do you say oh well I'm gonna
eat as much and drink as much as I can
because who knows I might died tomorrow
from it or do you say well I think I
probably need to change my diet these
are real life things that people go
through these are ethical questions too
by the way
so let's jump into the category no
different
yeah he's yeah I mean the only kinds of
nature yes but already as I think as you
suggested and by what we're looking at
is a well-ordered or a healthy soul yeah
rather than just whatever whatever we
happen to be whatever we give it yeah
and usually we start out with it by the
time we start looking at athletics we're
usually kind of screwed up
so so this stoicism presuppose already a
mind-body distinction they play off of
our soul you can say they play off of it
but ultimately the Stoics are
materialists so they they see the body
and the soul is composed of the same
kinds of substance but
you you can say that rather than being a
separation there is a distinction you
guys understand that we have instead of
saying them the soul on the body of two
different things they can be
distinguished from each other one we
certainly have more control over them
than the other right although even until
we we work our problems through a lot of
things within our minds are only partly
within our control you know like if I
have a bad temper because I grew up in a
household where everybody shouted at
each other and people routinely punched
each other in the nose or say thank
goodness I didn't the first yes the
second know I'm going to have a lot of
work to do in order to have a healthy
well ordered and soul this I could be
like snapping my fingers and suddenly I
have it whereas my body you know lesson
in my control
Zen answer adequately er well it goes in
another direction
sure anger is something that what leads
astray
yeah where does righteous indignation
righteous anger I yeah this is one of
those issues on which the Stoics were
like the arch enemies of the
Aristotelian and this is actually one of
the areas in which I do a lot of my my
work it's how I got interested in the
starts in the first place storks are
uncompromising angers always bad and
that's pretty hard to swallow because
well sometimes calm righteous
indignation you know there's there's
there's a arguments that begin like
Seneca says anything you can do under
the influence of anger you can do better
without feeling anger but acting
according to reason what reason tells
you you ought to do she does is to say
that a judge should probably appear to
be angry but don't actually be angry so
that the criminals will you know
straighten their out straighten their
ways a bit better but they other their
uncompromising about
and I think in the modern adaptations
there's some leeway for for anger but
it's still even for the Aristotelian
most instances of anger so let's talk
about what's what's in our control and
what's what's not in our control so they
the Stoics make a really strong
distinction between the things that are
in our control up to us another way of
translating our business you know things
that aren't in our control yeah we make
mistakes from a from a moral perspective
that are damaging to ourselves when we
get these mixed up so if we think that
things that really are not in our
control are in our control and the anger
is a great example of this because when
we get angry you often feel like we
control the situation more than we do
like somehow yelling at this person is
going to produce the response that we
want from them and they'll realize that
they were wrong
almost never works right but we still
keep doing it we're mixing up things
that are in our control and not in our
control and if we treat things that are
not in our control as if court in the
Stoics as if they're genuinely good
things our designer naturally goes out
to them and steers us to pursue those
things we think that wealth is
intrinsically valuable then we will
naturally sacrifice other things for
well if we think that social approval is
intrinsically valuable you know or even
useful to getting wealth or something
else then we're gonna pursue that and so
if we get mixed up about this we're
going to pursue the wrong things we're
also going to try to avoid the wrong
things too if we think that social
disapproval is the worst thing that
could possibly happen to us which is you
know fairly common human view about
things then that can keep us from
actually doing what we're supposed to do
and that's damaging to to ourselves it's
also going to be damaging to others so
we can actually give our minds over to
things that are
outside of our control and this happens
sometimes when we you know expect
Epictetus says things to go the way that
we want them to go in the universe so
for example I'll use a really silly
example I get I get upset with inanimate
objects a lot a lot more than I should
now get this nice you know dossier here
and oh I don't even have to use the
water bottle which irritated me earlier
today I'll just use this so this flap
here you know it doesn't sit the way
that I would like to get exactly and
sometimes it's in the way and I don't
unfortunately I'm not like it was when I
was a kid I probably kick it or hit it
or you know things like that but I do
get irritated like if it doesn't sit on
the car seat the right way now that's
stupid that's just completely from a
stoic perspective I'm really badly off
you know I am this this thing has no
control over how it behaves it's purely
mechanical right if I don't want it to
behave in a certain way maybe I can take
a little thought and not sit it up in
this way or not have the expectation
that it has to unfold itself exactly the
way I want it to so that's one thing the
other thing that comes up a lot is when
we when we try to get things that other
people have control over what would
those sort of things be what what don't
you control in your own life that other
people do control we're gonna be a group
you're really easy one in this classroom
right what don't you control that
somebody else controls well why can't
you just get up and leave it here
because you're bored with this yeah or
why can't you ask me a question you know
whatever you want to because you care a
little bit at least about what I think
don't you and the park is your pool I
hate them that's good I'm not
complaining about that right there's a
lot of things like this we you know
Conner's workout us by getting us to
agreed all sorts of things
and we shouldn't we shouldn't agree to
because we care about their approval and
we shouldn't care about most people's
approval we should care about our own
approval from our self or disapproval or
those few people who we actually think
have their heads screwed on right who
can give us valuable advice and
assessments of ourselves
what's a worry for example I'm going to
be a social media everybody I'm actually
I have Facebook Google+ Twitter
sometimes I get on reddit and I've
linked it and I post on on all of them
how many of you ever got upset when you
posted something really cool and nobody
liked it or followed it or tweeted it or
more invested in thinking that they
don't do that
from one again from a stoic person
that's something that's in somebody
else's control
yep ik Tina's goes so far as to say we
made ourselves the slave of the other
person when we try to seek something
that's in their control it can be grades
it can be any sort of gatekeeping thing
it can be who gives you a job it can be
who's going to pay you it can be
approval it can be all sorts of things
we're making a mistake again from a
stoic perspective when we we do that now
does that mean that we shouldn't care
about the outside world at all this goes
to those sort of questions not just
about health but about wealth and you
know reputation no because their use of
externals does in fact fall in our
control so we can use them well we use
them poorly we can use wealth
well we're used while poorly what would
be an example of using wealth well at
your stage as a student you don't have a
lot of what's up well if you can do that
that's great especially at your age cos
then you'll actually have something
I need something a little bit more
short-term what is what are the ones the
perennial thing for students that's
that's a hard one to swallow to Rex they
overcharge you in most cases there's
kind of a racket going on with textbooks
I really feel for students that sort of
thing won't be a bad use of your money
scant money that you have as a student
usually what's it oh yeah I wasn't even
thinking about that am i drinking so
things like drinking in bars if you're
gonna from a stoical perspective if
you're gonna spend your money on liquor
drink at home right don't drink at bars
but gambling yeah that's that almost
just cuts out the getting anything for
it so I mean these are these are ways in
which we use the resources that we have
and we can think about this in terms of
our contacts we can think about this in
terms of our reputation where we put
what we call our social capital when we
invest it into you know who do we vouch
for all that is actually up to us and
this leads us to two other important
concerns let's talk a little bit more
now about the virtues and vices
so if Stoics our virtue ethicists but
they're a weird kind of virtue ethicist
in that for the most part at least the
sort of party line is you've got a
virtue and you've got vice and there's
really nothing in between there's no
like you're your cat a virtuous cat a
vicious you're either good or you're bad
this is what they call the stoic paradox
now in practice the Stoics do understand
that there is you know moral progress
habits play an important role
breaking your old bad habits replacing
them with good habits that's all very
important but the Stoics want to stress
look you're either making progress
towards virtue or is balling blessing
you're falling back
to vice and the virtues advices that
they acknowledge were the big four what
we call the cardinal virtues and then
they're opposed vices wisdom which
includes practical wisdom thinking about
how you want to run your life what's
what's good for you you know temperance
or moderation you know not taking more
than as excessive that has to do with
the body for example can conduce to help
as well right courage which they thought
was very important you needed not only
to understand what the good is but to be
able to stand up against hostility
against resistance against temptation
when things get tricky
and then justice and justice is quite
interesting because when we here then
we're justice we tend to think of like
crime and punishment or you know I owe
somebody something
the Stoics distinguished between justice
and that's our a strict sense and then
they also talked about benevolence doing
good for other people is falling under
justice that if we were going to be
truly just it's not just a matter of
following the rules and I'm not screwing
anybody over not breaking any any you
know rules or duties but it's also going
beyond and being benevolent to other
people so that's you know that that's an
important way of looking at things then
the question is well how would we
develop these the Stoics placed a really
strong emphasis on like I said habit but
also on thinking if we can change our
thinking about things we can change the
ways in which we behave the ways in
which we react and the ways in which we
feel so wisdom really is the most
important virtue it kind of governs the
rest of them for the Stoics and these
are the stories that capacities that we
all have with those so this is another
way in which it's a little bit different
than other virtue ethics some virtue out
looks like Aristotle's would say look
you start out and you're cut your own he
doesn't say actually you're a blank
slate when it comes to virtue since you
know you don't actually have virtues
reply
so you might have like tendencies
towards certain behaviors tendencies
towards others some people are more
irritable than others some people are
more easygoing than others but actually
developing a real virtue or a vice that
takes some work that takes some some
time doesn't take some repetition the
Stoics say you have the capacity within
you to be virtuous if you choose so
you're always sort of on the hook for it
may be harder to exercise that capacity
for some people than others like for me
the reason I got interested in anger to
begin with so I have a bad temper and I
still do I just mostly keep it under
control I haven't turned into the virtue
that would be associated which is not be
having a really good temper right the
you know the Stoics would say I always
have the capacity to not lose my temper
if I choose to that's that's something
that's that's up to me but I have to
actually decide to do that and being
told that you have the capacity is very
liberating because a lot of times in
modern culture we're told that we don't
really have any control over our
emotions they just are the way they are
and that's it we were stuck with them
same thing with our desires we're often
told that you know we just desire the
things that we do you know and we have
to follow out our desires we can do the
rational layer of your reaction away but
we're stuck with these particular
desires stoicism says no we we are
responsible for those and we can steer
those in a virtuous way or vicious ways
so this requires choices to be made
determinative choices easier by the way
to mate when you're your age the Stoics
think then when you're our age when your
character is already a bit more fixed so
you have you have a better shot at it
than we do the other Lane you've gotten
to the point where you're bigger
committed yeah so the last thing that
you know I think it's really useful to
take away from if you want to say I
understand something about stoic ethics
you notice an epic
talks a lot about duties and he says at
one point that our duties are measured
by our roles of our relationships so
this is where we see a connection not
just you know ourself and like it
officer I need to figure out what's
really in my power what's not in my
power how I can be virtuous all that
sort of that looks like I withdraw from
the world how do we engage with other
people that's where stomachs thought
that Duty is is particularly important
so other people are strictly speaking
external to us right I don't decide
whether you are a good person or a bad
person so it shouldn't really affect me
but I do have certain duties towards you
for example like showing up and I was
you know drunk and didn't have any notes
and just stood up here and told jokes
would you like that would be a nice
break from classes
I think somebody'd be like what what is
wrong with this guy you know he was
supposed to what come here and tell us
about something I have certain duties as
a speaker to an audience all of us
inhabit all these roles right I mean a
father and a son and this sibling so
there's these familial walls I'm also a
educator I suppose that comes with a
whole bunch of other roles I have a
business just a mom-and-pop thing so we
don't have employees that I have to
worry about the appliance and then we
have rules like being fellow citizen
neighbor trapped with each of those come
obligations to the other person and the
Stoics say it's up to you whether you
recognize and fulfill those obligations
and we're often placed in situations
where we don't want to why not there's
there's let me take one thing off the
board
we often have situations where like
fulfilling obligations is just kind of a
pain and you know it requires us to not
do something else that we'd like to do
and so you know we're not acting like a
good son or daughter or a good mom or
dad you know some of the time because of
that the White House what makes us
really say well I'm not gonna behave
that way towards that person when do we
most make excuses for ourselves yeah so
Epictetus talks about a guy who has a
brother and the brother is acting like a
jerk yeah and he's not being a very good
brother at all and Epictetus system well
you know you have a choice just because
he acts like a jerk doesn't mean that
you should act like a jerk of turn
because the logic behind that is well
he's damaging himself he's damaging the
good person inside of him who he could
have chosen to be so in response to that
I'm gonna wrap the good person inside of
myself
and I'm not gonna be a brother to him
the Stoics and that's crazy
if that's that's foolishness instead we
we have control over how we fulfill our
duties to other people does that mean
that we should just allow them to walk
all over us and take advantage of us
what do you think do you think the
Stoics insane that would lead to that I
mean it sounds kind of like that doesn't
it
yes yeah in some cases I mean there's
there's there are some people that are
really you know you know they see you
doing that they're like I can totally
take advantage of her right so I mean
the stomachs are not saying you
shouldn't have any proper boundaries
sometimes you shouldn't break off a
relationship think about a Beus of
relationship with a boyfriend or
girlfriend's constantly taking
advantages of you being a stomach right
at a certain point you do actually have
to say know why because you also have
duties to yourself you know you
shouldn't have to put up with with that
sort of thing but the storks are going
to counsel a lot more forgiving people
giving people the benefit of the doubt
trying to be on the that I try and
understand their position doesn't mean
that you don't say to them hey you're
being a jerk but there's no expectation
that by you telling something like a
jerk that they're automatically going to
change and so this can actually lead to
a lot more peace of mind for yourself
and it's through fulfilling our duties
that we in fact live out the virtues so
just at the point yeah if you're if you
refuse to become a jerk toward your
brother because he's a jerk but if you
do that makes you a less of a person
yeah is that a totally selfish
motivation no you're not some kind of an
obligation of probably well yeah our
affection you're doing it in order not
to diminish yourself yeah this is what
this is one of those cases where you
know our common way of like opposing
selfishness versus other centeredness
just breaks down the Stoics and this
holds for a lot of other great genetics
to the Stoics would say that you know
when it comes to certain things that
opposition between like being totally
selfish and caring about the other being
concerned about the other that does well
like say with Wow right but when it
comes to the genuine good and living a
rational life in you know as much
harmony with other people as we can I'm
actually benefiting them by working on
my own character it's not just you know
and this is where a lot of that just
dudes in general know
very clearly not for the Stoics I mean
they say things like that time and time
and time again it's it's not you know me
as epic tedious will say maintaining the
person of fidelity
he likes that term a lot pista within
within a person within myself the person
who actually fulfills obligations it's
not something it is something that I can
take pleasure in myself and I can say
I'm a great guy and I like Who I am but
it's not if it was just for that reason
I'd have lost sight of what I'm doing I
wouldn't really be maintaining that with
that person something inevitably
contradictions would arise it would show
that instead of what I'm doing is I'm
I'm becoming part of a whole a rational
whole this is actually where I was going
to move towards us that we all can
participate in the start to talk in
terms of a that store to the ones uses
from cosmopolitanism and we associate
with a magazine but cosmopolitan really
means citizen of the world somebody who
sees the whole world is filled with
fellow human beings to whom they can
have good relations if those other human
beings are up to him and the Stoics
would talk in terms of a kingdom of all
rational beings this is where it gets
very damn too logical right very much
like hunt and to work upon myself and to
make myself less of a screw-up than it
means to be able to participate more
fully in that common well now that there
may not be a lot of people on that kind
of law you may inhabit a society where
everybody's crazy and everybody's making
the wrong choices and the whole culture
is against you and I'm not just thinking
about saying that American consumeristic
Society with you know advertisements in
your face all the time
designed to arouse your desires as much
as possible that's already tough to
think about living in a totalitarian
society you know we're questioning the
government will get you killed
then get your family killed and the
media is not just giving you sort of a
mishmash of stuff that's
probably not very edifying and it tends
to be very commercial driven but it has
a very clear message the state is what
matters and you don't matter at all any
good citizen means be willing to write
on your friends yeah yeah I mean it'd be
very difficult I think in a situation
like that to develop properly and so you
know if you inhabit a society like that
you'd that you know it's not that it's
totally impossible because there's
always some people who were like no no
there's there's more than this but it's
very very difficult to me that's where
stoicism is particularly attractive
though - yeah like I feel like if I was
a stoic I have an easier time in a
totalitarian kind of situation just for
the fact that they counsel in that
instance that detachment right a sense
that of what you control what you have
within your control the less and less
you have within your control in that
general Commonwealth right I mean you
can cultivate your everything so it's
been taken away from you man yeah you're
cultivating your own dirt virtuous self
but this but the Commonwealth is broken
or something right seems like that's an
easier thing to reconcile for a stoic
than maybe for other that's true well
you know one of the famous 20th century
starts is Admiral Stockdale and he wrote
this very famous piece talking about how
he applied epictetus is enchiridion in a
Vietnamese prison of prisoner of war
camp where they did horrible things to
these prisoners just just to screw them
and trying to break them down and he
said stoicism is very useful for
environments like that the trouble is
just like epic two assistants you know
just knowing you know what what the
enchiridion says that's not gonna that's
not gonna work for very long you know
you have to made it part of yourself and
this is this holds for any system of
ethics though so this is a good place to
close and take any any final questions
any moral theory any system of ethics
only really works when it has become
part of the fabric of who you are when
it's not just something in a book but
it's something that you practice and
something that you make progress in and
something that you reflect up that means
this the last thing I'd really like to
say and I think this is probably when it
comes to that sort of stuff the most
important thing you're if you're going
to be
a person who tries to live a thoughtful
ethical life you're going to screw up
much of the time you're going to fail
and then we're an ethics really it's
interesting is what you do with your
failure how you get yourself back up
Epictetus says it's just like being a
wrestler you know get knocked down six
times
get up seven and get back in the ring
and that's how you get stronger and
that's one of the things that I think
walking get sucked up in teaching ethics
right the fact that you will fail and
what counts the most is what you do
after that
whether you say oh well it's too hard I
give up or whether you say AHA what can
I fix what can I do differently next
time what do I need to rethink what
resources doing it so what questions do
you guys have about stoic ethics where
is this well Menninger they usually
leave at 10 - okay I'm just I may have
failed to remind you that just because
they're passing between classes so any
questions that you've got happy to
answer if any occur to you my email is
there situations you're living in if
you're wealthy then you get access to
good health care and good education and
you have more exposure to there's two
things to say about that
one answer the question like where does
virtue come from
it's a capacity within us and if you
think about the asset ease within you or
not
radically different than the capacities
within being rational human beings so we
share a common nature but if you develop
justice and I don't well justice
you know actually exists in here and
I've managed to ruin it within myself
you could keep you could be as just as
you wanted it wouldn't necessarily make
me anymore just so where did where does
it where I could be adjustable if you're
if you don't have justice within you
can't you build it oh yes yes that and
that's one of the things that I think is
very optimistic about the stoic
viewpoint that if you realize that
you're vicious that doesn't that's not
the end of the story oh I'm vicious
forget it I'm done right no then then if
you actually care about that you know
wow I don't really want to be vicious
any more any day and then there's
questions like what resources so the
stomach's on 40 chains there's there's
like actual practices that they they use
to try to cultivate these sorts of
things like for example taking stock of
the day at the end of the day and
thinking about what you did well and
what you did poorly that got assimilated
later on and then the Christian
examination of conscience as a common
practice but the stove's were doing that
earlier no to the other thing about it's
called social inequalities right and the
fact that some people have much better
situations that make induced to them
being more virtuous than others or it
may not because you know if you grew up
in a wealthy household there's more
temptations there's more things you can
easily lose yourself in as well and it
depends on having people I think in your
life we're gonna steer you the right
wedding and that's one thing we can say
a sort of a constant over time looking
at it cross culturally and throughout
history the wealthy aren't usually any
better morally than the rest of us and
that also means that they're not usually
much worse you know there's kind of a
smattering some we're really great
people
some and they managed to use their
wealth really well and sterling
well some of there's terrible people but
then some of the people who are poor
would be the same terrible people who
gave them some money and some of them
would be really really good but there
are other things like you say like
healthcare right big issue for us we
don't have an equal access to health
care and not even I live in Wisconsin I
think we're better off than you guys are
here in Illinois partners your state is
bankrupt and we're not you know but it's
still not great for us unless you buy
the very expensive plans now what would
a stoic have to say about that I think a
stoic if we look at the Starks who
actually live they would be Frick for
fixing that sort of stuff they would
want to see like the health care system
be equalized so that people who are rich
don't get it you know way better health
care than other people they would be for
you know making society better now that
doesn't necessarily lead to any
particular political doctrine there's
been a lot of discussions and the stoic
forms of well you should start vote for
this party or this party and it doesn't
really translate quite like that I think
it'd be more like an issue-by-issue the
Stoics also thought you should
participate in politics they that you
know if you if you're in a society where
you have a role of being a citizen that
you should actually participate you
should vote you should you should take
office if you can and make things better
that's kind of an interesting
[Applause]